ce colomé bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation l'épidémie de korla
virus gagne du terrain en espagne la
catalogne est toujours en zone rouge
pourtant queen tu auras président de la
région a rétropédalé en autorisant la
manifestation à barcelone comment est-ce
que vous interprétez cette décision
alors bonjour non s'il n'y a aucune
interprétation c'est à dire que monsieur
kinko tora le président de la caritas a
permis parce que c'était dans son plan
de faire un acte symbolique c'est
d'encercler tous les institutions
espagnoles de barcelone entre elles par
exemple mur c'était le barcelone
lagence tributaire etc l'assemblée
nationale catalane a inscrit des
volontaires 48000 pour cet encerclement
de haut pour les indépendantistes de la
présence de l'état espagnol en catalogne
c'est à dire que il y aura pas une
manifestation comme on a vu dans cet
avis sinon d un élément symbolique de
d'encercler c'est un bâtiment pour
dénoncer la présence de l'état espagnol
en catalogne
des rassemblements vont quand même vont
avoir lieu dans
dans la région et notamment à barcelone
cela pourrait avoir la guerre des
conséquences dans la crise sanitaire si
jamais les contaminations exposeront les
prochains jours est ce que le
gouvernement espagnol pourrait s'en
servir
il pourrait s'en servir mais il va pas
le faire parce que c'est un acte de la
communauté autonome les compétences
sanitaires sont de la communauté
autonome c'est à dire que politiquement
il peut s'en servir mais ça va pas
passer de là c'est à dire que tout le
reste de santé hôpitaux sont une
compétence exclusive de la catalogne
c'est à dire que ce qui va se passer
aujourd'hui c'est avec la permission du
gouvernement catalan pour faire un acte
de revendication nationaliste
c'est vrai que ils vont pas faire un
rassemblement de 50000 personnes
en principe on sait jamais mais c'est
vrai que lira des des problèmes parce
que 50000 personnes avec masques ou le
sans masque il ya danger de de contagion
sa route il est une rupture au sein de
la coalition indépendantiste car excusé
monte car on peut avec son parti quelles
conséquences à terme pour la région
la conséquence est que on devait devrait
avoir des élections
en principe on pensait que ce serait
vers novembre mais la stratégie de
waterloo de pouce demande c'est de
d'arriver jusqu'au mois de février à peu
près pour voir ces élections parce que
comme ça il pourra construire son
nouveau artefacts qui n'est pas
appartient nous duarte fact électorale
pour arriver à ces élections avec des
possibilités de gagner c'est à dire que
on va voir dans les prochains jours
blocage le blocus du parlement lan
habilitation du président tu auras va
faire que le parlement et les
institutions ce bloc et il y aura un la
dissolution automatique du parlement
vers novembre à peu près et à partir de
là élections mode furie justement ces
élections qui sont retardés en raison de
l'épidémie de coronavirus quels en
seront les enjeux les enjeux c'est que
pour la première fois la coalition
indépendantiste et j'ai tout aimé tout à
fait fractionnez fragmenté c'est dire
c'est à dire que les sondages disent une
chose mais la guerre interne très très
forte et à plusieurs partis qui vont se
présenter c'est pas évident que la
coalition indépendantiste gagne par
majorité absolue la cré de tout tout
tout ce qui peut se passer en février
c'est si le bloc indépendantiste
maintient sa majorité absolue au
parlement où finalement ce match nul
quand on voit 2 million à 2 millions
permet que sans majorité absolue il on
commence à voir une géométrie politique
et électoral et de gouvernement tout à
fait différente pour essayer de comme
supposé monde ne soit pas l'élément je
dirais de distorsion dans le système
politique catalan c'est à dire quelqu'un
qui est à bruxelles est en train de
marquer l'agenda politique en catalogne
merci beaucoup gabriel colomé d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de sciences
politiques à barcelone